die hilft aus auch aus ihrer sicht jetzt
nur noch die vollbremsung
ja leider es gibt ja auch vieles anders
sehen deswegen will ich schon mal ein
bisschen kritischen punkt an bringen ich
gehöre zu denen die in dem moment als im
november datei lockdown beschlossen
wurde gesagt haben das verstehe ich
nicht die restaurants die
kultureinrichtungen die waren als für
die kunden dennoch nachverfolgen können
nachweislich nicht im fokus waren keine
treiber der pandemie und dass gerade die
bereiche uns jetzt dann im winter
ausreichend sollen um die zahlen runter
zu kriegen habe ich nie geglaubt und
habe mit kollegen den brief an den
ministerpräsidenten geschrieben wo das
dokumentiert ist dass wir gesagt haben
dieser teil locker und der muss doch
dann ein halbes jahr gehen bis zum
frühjahr und wir kommen jetzt glaube ich
in die große schwierigkeit dass man den
leuten hoffnungen gemacht hat auch
weihnachten dass das konzept erkennbar
nicht funktioniert hatte und dass man
jetzt nachträglich alles wieder umwerfen
muss es war ja die botschaft november
und dann geht es euch allen wieder gut
diese großen enttäuschungen machen sie
jetzt glaube ich schwöre ich noch mal
eine kraftanstrengung hinzukriegen aber
ich sage auch ich sehe keine alternative
wäre wir müssen die weihnachtspause
nutzen um die zahlen runter zu kriegen
ich frage das mal in die runde wenn man
sich so und guckt in europa hat es ja
schon länder gegeben frankreich italien
belgien wo man diesen harten schnitt
schon viel früher gemacht hat mit sehr
positiven ergebnissen allerdings auch
mit einem landsmann jo jo effekt so
lange die harten maßnahmen gehalten
gegen die zahlen runter werden sie
gelockert wurden gingen sie dann auch
wieder hoch trotzdem man hat es immerhin
gemacht gucken wir nicht ein bisschen
sehr geduldig zu wie bei uns die hütte
brennt es war schon so dass die leute um
herrn meier man rum diese modelle
präsentiert und meyer hermann und dass
man in der politik den erst mal geglaubt
hat ich habe sie nicht geglaubt ich fand
sie nicht plausibel
ein bisschen mathematik studiert hat ist
alles nicht eingeleuchtet aber jetzt hat
die politik diesen versuch gemacht und
er ist offenkundig gescheitert wir haben
die emotionalen ressourcen stark
strapaziert wir haben viel geld
ausgegeben
die zahlen gehen nicht runter das war
einfach eine schlechte strategie das war
natürlich so dass es schon eine gewisse
vorstellung gab dass man die zahl der
kontakte mindestens um die hälfte
reduziert da hat uns die wissenschaftler
auch gesagt das müsst ihr tun und dann
haben einige maßnahmen die einstimmige
unterstützung aller bekommen aber eine
ganze reihe anderer maßnahmen war nicht
einigungsfähig und dadurch war es am
ende zu wenig
das zweite war das glaube ich ganz viele
nicht die bürgerinnen und bürger die
haben uns immer unterstützt
aber ganz viele die entscheiden müssen
auch diese exponentielle gefahr die von
dem wachstum ausgeht nicht sehen
wir haben ja erlebt dass sich die
kanadier haben doch aber schon vor vier
vor zwei monaten hat die kanzlerin schon
gesagt sein werden wir 19.200 haben
der wert wurde heute erreicht danach an
dem an dem an dem dröhnen schweigen
vieler kann man auch sehen dass es
wahrscheinlich den meisten peinlich war
aber das ändert ja nichts daran dieses
exponentielle wachstum heißt übrigens
wenn man erstmal bei 25 26 tausend
fällen angekommen ist kann man sehr
schnell woche 50.000 sein wenn wir das
in unserem bei unseren freunden in
frankreich gesehen hat die haben es gott
sei dank geschafft und die kurve
bekommen und deshalb sollten wir nicht
pessimistisch sein aber wir haben jetzt
noch einen schuss sozusagen dem wir vor
weihnachten gemeinsam organisieren
müssen
und das muss dazu führen dass wir anfang
des jahres wirklich deutlich
zurückgehende zahlen haben und ich
gehöre zu denen die sagen lockerungen
kann es nur geben wenn zahlen
zurückgehen
wir können nicht sagen wir versprechen
euch es sind nur vier wochen sind nur
zehn tage der einzige entscheidende
punkt ist gehen die zahlen zurück ist
das gesundheitssystem handlungsfähig
oder müssen wir noch eine zeitlang des
weiter durch wir haben zwei fehler
gemacht und ein problem und das dürfen
wir alles nicht wiederholen die fehler
waren erst dieses katzen konzert der
ministerpräsidenten die sich hier über
all das haben sie hier schon sehr schön
dargestellt immer wieder andere lösungen
ausgedacht haben wer sollte dem noch
folgen können das zweite war meine
profession wir haben auch streitig
diskutiert wir haben noch nie in unserem
leben so schnell wissenschaft nach außen
transportiert und was wir als normalen
wissenschaftlichen streit empfunden
haben kamen der öffentlichkeit als der
streit unter kesselflicker
das darf sich nicht wiederholen das
dritte ist dass prävention spa dogs
worden wir haben es geschafft in der
ersten welle
anders als alle anderen länder die über
sterblichkeit auf 0 praktisch zu bringen
wir da hat es dann leute geben gern und
gibt das virus überhaupt damit haben wir
die menschen in falscher sicherheit
gewiegt und das ist unser problem heute
dagegen hilft
nur ein konsequenter lockdown und da ist
die weihnachtszeit meines erachtens ist
die beste war dann die wirtschaftlichen
und die schulischen kollateralschäden am
geringsten sind
frage an den wirtschaftsminister wäre es
denn nicht klüger gewesen die reißleine
zu ziehen im november werden im november
etwa also dort deutlich früher um dann
nicht ins weihnachtsgeschäft
reinzuquetschen ja ich bin ja erst mal
kein mediziner aber als laie hat mich
das schon beunruhigt als für praktisch
ab ende juli eine ständige steigerung
hatten von 300 fällen am tag auf 901
1500 dann waren 2004 hat nun so lange
wird wir hatten uns daran gewöhnt so
hätte man damals die kraft gehabt so
handelt hätte hätte fahrradkette
dann wären uns viele einschränkungen
erspart geblieben und viele kosten auch
den wirtschaftsminister blutet das herz
boris palmer hat doch recht
die restaurantbesitzer die café besitzer
die haben alles getan um die risiken zu
minimieren
übrigens viele andere auch im
erwerbsleben bei den modeboutiquen
überall in den kultureinrichtungen und
trotzdem sind wir gezwungen
einschränkungen zu verlangen denn und zu
verhängen
denn ansonsten reduzieren wir die zahl
der sozialen kontakte nicht und das ist
sozusagen die größte ansteckungsquelle
und ich glaube sie haben einen finger
natürlich in die wunde gelegt wird sie
gesagt haben es gibt noch andere werte
aber wir haben uns eigentlich zu beginn
der pandemie darauf verständigt dass der
wert des menschlichen lebens und der
gesundheit einen ziemlich hohen
stellenwert hat weil wir eben nicht
wollen dass am ende die älteren alle
sterben und ich bin ja wirklich auch
beeindruckt was in tübingen da geleistet
worden ist ganz offenbar wenn man den
zahlen die zahlen liest bei ihnen in den
altenheimen und anderswo kommen wir
gleich das heißt das heißt wir müssen
das dann auch durchhalten denn mein
eindruck ist in vielen gesprächen dass
die übergroße mehrheit der bevölkerung
genau das versteht und auch möchte dass
der staat so handelt frau pflaster ich
gebe gern damals auf weihnachten zurück
kommen sie wissen dass wir vielleicht
auch aus anderen ländern sind wir
deutschen da speziell in unserer
fokussierung auf diese drei tage mir
kommt das schon so vor also ich arbeite
sehr viel mit franzosen zusammen und
die können es nicht so richtig
nachvollziehen also dass jetzt dieses
weihnachten irgendwie das große thema
ist und dass man da jetzt unbedingt eine
pause vom lockdown braucht und verlage
etwas irrationales hat wie herr
montgomery richtig gesehen
das finde ich eigentlich aus meiner
perspektive die interessante frage was
sind eigentlich die irrationalen anteile
in den unterschiedlichen positionen und
dieses weihnachten diese weihnachts
fixierung die gehört ganz ganz bestimmt
dazu ich glaube wenn er noch aufs impfen
kommen dann werden wir auch sicherlich
über einige irrationale anteile reden
aber eben auch über durchaus berechtigte
fragen die man haben kann
an diese impfstoffe die jetzt da gerade
so als heilsversprechen irgendwie in den
raum gestellt werden
also ich hab da zumindest noch einige
fragen die mir bisher noch nicht so
richtig gut beantwortet wird können sie
diese später an das klima ja zu den
berechtigten fragen die viele
bürgerinnen und bürger stellen gehört ja
auch was gilt jetzt eigentlich in meinem
bundesland da sind die leute schauen oft
nicht mehr durch frau dreyer die frage
vielleicht auch noch mal an sie sie
leben und regieren ja an einer
nahtstelle in der landeshauptstadt mainz
für rheinland pfalz und müssen nur
einmal über den rhein fahren dann sieben
sind sie in wiesbaden in der
landeshauptstadt von hessen und die
maßnahmen sind nicht identisch das ist
den leuten schwer zu erklären das ist
das eine
aber es hat auch ein risiko weil da wo
geschlossen wird können natürlich die
leute dann wegfahren als nächste
bundesland und da bei ihren
einkaufstouren zum neuen risiko werden
sehen sie das also wir versuchen uns
schon in unseren nachbarländern im
groben abzustimmen und das funktioniert
im großen ganzen auch gut und im übrigen
stimmen wir uns auch sogar mit unseren
ausländischen nachbarn in der
grenzregion ab und ich will auch noch
mal sagen ich finde es auch ein bisschen
komisch dass jetzt permanent dieses
bashing stattfindet gegenüber den
ministerpräsidenten mir gefällt es
manchmal auch nicht wenn der eine oder
der andere sich immer wieder so
vorprescht und martialische zetsche sagt
und was auch immer
das dient der sache nicht aber es dient
auch nicht der sache dass immer der
eindruck vermittelt wird der
föderalismus ist das hauptproblem
ich möchte einmal daran erinnern wir
haben extrem unterschiedliche
situationen in deutschland gehabt und
wir haben sie auch jetzt noch jetzt ist
die lage überall eigentlich zu
schlechten kann man allgemein sagen aber
es hätte kein mensch verstanden wenn im
sommer das haben wir vor uns drüber
geredet bei niedrigen zahlen teilweise
in manchen bundesländern bei so gut wie
gar keinen zahlen wenn man bundesweit
einheitliche restriktionen gemacht hätte
das darf man jetzt auch nicht gerade mal
so schwarz-weiß darstellen
es wäre auch gar nicht möglich gewesen
nicht vermittelbar gewesen an die
bevölkerung aber auch rechtlich nicht
möglich gewesen
es sind enorme grundrechtseingriffe die
wir tun und deshalb ist der vorteil
eines föderalen systems auch der dass
man natürlich auch spezifisch reagieren
kann und mein letzter satz ist natürlich
müssen wir an es war immer meine haltung
in den großen linien gemeinsam gehen und
deshalb hoffe ich auch darauf dass wir
jetzt diesen lockdown gemeinsam
beschließen in die rahmenbedingungen
aber ich warne auch ein bisschen davor
so zu tun als gäbe es zwei schuldige
nach herr montgomery nämlich einmal die
ministerpräsidentin gar nicht
wiederholen was er jetzt zugesagt hat
und auf der anderen zeit die ärzteschaft
ist einfach zu einfach gemacht und ich
sage auch noch mal auch wenn wir jetzt
wieder in der bredouille sind insgesamt
ist deutschland bis jetzt sehr gut durch
die krise gekommen und unser ehrgeiz
muss sein dass wir mit den bürgern
bürgerinnen jetzt diese phase gut
gestalten damit wir dann auch wieder
stück für stück in ein stück weitere
normalität kommen könne nicht einmal
konkrete nachfragen vor treuer rechnen
sie dann jetzt damit dass dieser große
locker und vor weihnachten kommt oder
nicht
es wäre völlig unredlich ist eben jetzt
hier in dieser sendung zu beantworten
die leopoldina das ist sind sie ja die
vielzitierte nationale akademie auch von
der bundeskanzlerin hat ja vorgeschlagen
nach weihnachten mit dem knock down zu
gewinnen zu beginnen heute höre ich
etwas anderes aus dem bundeskanzleramt
wir haben auch sehr deutlich gemacht
dass wir vorstellungen haben ich sage am
ende wird es darum gehen dass wir
gemeinsam marschieren und da kommt es
nicht darauf an ob er von drei tage mehr
oder weniger sprechen sondern es kommt
darauf an dass wir die situation abwägen
und gemeinsam marschieren und vielleicht
auch noch einen einzigen satz
auch zu zeigen wie kompliziert
eigentlich auch alles ist natürlich
haben wir auch eine verantwortung der
wirtschaft gegenüber
und natürlich ist es jetzt gerade das
weihnachtsgeschäft dieses eben
angesprochen worden und wir müssen
natürlich jetzt einen weg finden dass
nicht alle leute die nächsten drei tage
die geschichte geschäfte über rennen um
ihre einkäufe zu machen um ihre
geschenke zu kaufen was auch immer
sondern eine vernünftige lösung zu
finden immer an aller vorderster stelle
natürlich das thema gesundheit und die
zahlen die uns jetzt gerade davon laufen
aber auf der anderen seite eben auch so
dass wir hand in hand wirklichen ganz
deutschland miteinander gehen können nur
das verstehen die bürger und bürgerinnen
in einer so harten eingriff situation
auf last oder möchte ja ich wollte noch
mal ganz kurz auf einen altmaier
eingehen weil sie ja sagten auch zu
recht da wir haben uns darauf
verständigt dass das leben für uns im
vordergrund steht was auch vollkommen
richtig ist aber man kann sich natürlich
auch eine situation vorstellen gerade
jetzt wenn wir über weihnachten reden
dass vielleicht eine großfamilie sagt
gut die großmutter ist schon sehr alt
hermann weiß nicht wie viele gemeinsame
weihnachten man noch erleben will und
wenn ich jetzt immer so höre dann also
auf gar keinen fall treffen die es schon
so alt auf gar keinen fall man darf sie
bloß nicht anstecken aber vielleicht
entscheidet sich auch diese alte dame
ich gehe das risiko ein ja ich möchte
das gerne trotzdem mit euch feiern ich
gehe das risiko ein womit ich nur sagen
will
die tatsache dass wir risiken heute sehr
gut kennen und auch berechnen können
weitgehend auch im falle des corona
virus inzwischen heißt der nicht
notwendigerweise immer dass man die
risiken auch sozusagen komplett
vermeidet man kann sich auch in gruppen
darauf verständigen dass man bestimmte
risiken ganz bewusst auch ein geht ja
und ich finde das gerät manchmal so ein
bisschen aus dem blick das ist völlig
normal sie wollen antworten auch ja ich
heute frau drei antworten vor weil nicht
die ärzteschaft als solche ist daran
schuld sondern der transport des
diskurses innerhalb der wissenschaft wir
haben das auch wirklich vielleicht
gleichzeitig gemacht eine zeit lang aber
ich würde gerne etwas sagen zu ihrem
wort der verhältnismäßigkeit das ist ja
ein juristisches ein juristischer
terminus den wir immer beachten müssen
das virus kennt keine
verhältnismäßigkeit das verhält sich
nicht verhältnismäßig und wenn ich sehe
sein oberverwaltungsgericht dann
einreisebeschränkungen auch
nordrhein-westfalen kippt weil in einer
nachbarregion höhere instanz zahlen
gelten dann ist das nicht
unverhältnismäßig und auch nicht das ist
dumm weil wir müssen auch
unverhältnismäßig auf dieses virus
reagieren anders haben wir keine chance
und deswegen sage ich nochmal den locker
möglichst bald ich teile die auffassung
von frau frontfrau drei ja dass man den
menschen die chance geben muss nur mein
glaube wir können da war ja nicht alle
unsere werte über bord schmeißen und
sozusagen die chinesische lösung problem
sagen die leute eiligst wir tun wir das
nicht und zweitens ist das virus kümmert
sich nicht darum
der entscheidende punkt ist doch können
wir das was autoritäre oder totalitären
staaten per ordre de mufti unter
einschränkungen aller freiheiten und
auch erreichen können wir das auf
anderem wege mit den bürgern mit der
gesellschaft mit dem start erreichen so
und die bereitschaft dazu ist vorhanden
es gibt auch einige die das bewusst
missachten aber die leute wollen
natürlich von uns auch klarheit haben
und ich bin habe ich damit mal drei auch
viele von diesen diskussionen erlebt
ich glaube jeder versteht es wenn wir
differenzieren nach unterschiedlichen
situationen vor ort wenn in
mecklenburg-vorpommern oder
schleswig-holstein die inzidenz deutlich
unter 50 ist und es so gut wie keine
todesfälle gibt dann muss man
gegebenenfalls auch denen die
möglichkeit geben
nicht ganz so streng zu verfahren wie
andere wo die inzidenz zehnmal so hoch
ist oder 20 mal so hoch ist und das habe
ich großen respekt vor michael
kretschmer der in sachsen lange zeit
verschont schien und dann plötzlich war
das virus an allen ecken und enden
und er hat sich mit seinem kabinett
entschieden ein klares signal zu setzen
und sie fangen bereits jetzt in der
nächsten woche hat vor allen dingen sehr
transparent gesagt wir haben fehler
gemacht du hast ja auch keine schande ja
das ist finde ich richtig und das
bedeutet dann aber im umkehrschluss auch
dass wir dann bereits müssen denen die
davon betroffen sind zu helfen
wir werden nicht mit der gießkanne geld
verteilen können aber ich finde es nicht
mehr als gerecht
so wie wir kurzarbeit machen für die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer dass
auch derjenige der fixkosten hat oder
seine miete zahlen muss weil er sein
wer sein geschäft versorgen muss dass er
die möglichkeit hat dafür vom staat
einen zuschuss zu bekommen und wir
werden das auch sicherstellen dass es so
ist damit auch der zusammenhalt nicht
verloren geht
ich möchte gerne einmal den blick öffnen
in dieser phase wo wir alle sehr aus
verständlichen gründen sehr fixiert sind
auf die bekämpfung der korona krise herr
montgomery ich frage den arzt in der
runde
es gibt doch offensichtlich auch
gefährliche nebenwirkungen dieser
fixierung ich sag mal menschen mit
anderen schweren krankheiten die sich
nicht mehr zum arzt trauen weil sie
angst haben als risikopatienten sind
auch corona einzufangen ist das etwas
was ihnen sorge macht was real
stattfindet ja das findet real statt das
hat übrigens in der ersten im ersten
teil der welle noch im frühjahr haben
sehr viel mehr stattgefunden als jetzt
die menschen haben angst zum arzt zu
gehen und die menschen verschleppen
erkrankungen also insbesondere bei
krankheiten die sich langsam an andeuten
und die prävention angesagt wäre da
findet momentan zu wenig statt und das
werden wir das wird uns einholen wenn
diese corona epidemie vorbei ist also
krebs herz kreislauf erkrankungen
diabetes hypertonie oder bluthochdruck
das sind all die erkrankung die momentan
unter normal behandelt werden kommunale
einsatz
das wird uns noch einholen aber das
jetzt haben wir eine akute
lebensbedrohung und ich bin immer dafür
erst mal die das größere problem zu
lösen und dann das zweite aber sie haben
völlig recht man muss die menschen
darauf hinweisen die arztpraxis ist kein
ort wo man sich ansteckt gehen sie zu
ihrem hat machen sie ihre normalen
untersuchungen weiter sonst haben wir
hinterher ein noch größeres problem frau
flaßpöhler wir hören es gerade wir
zahlen verschiedene preise in dieser
krise auch menschen die gar kein corona
haben
was macht denn dieses virus mit uns mit
unserer gesellschaft wie verändert dass
das zusammenleben
ich glaube also außerdem offensichtlich
dass wir distanz halten müssen genau ich
glaube auf ganz ganz vielen ebenen
natürlich aber ich finde was dieses
virus noch mal deutlich zeigt und die
situation in der wir uns jetzt auch
befinden macht es nochmal sichtbar wie
sehr unsere gesellschaft insgesamt auch
vertrauen erstmal angelegt ist ja also
als eine komplexe moderne
fortschrittliche gesellschaft sind wir
ganz fundamental in ganz
unterschiedlichen lebensbereichen auf
vertrauen in experten angewiesen schon
wenn ich morgens in mein auto steige das
ich nicht habe aber nicht stiege in
eines würde ich darauf vertrauen
automatisch dass dieses autos müssen es
ja auch alles möglich dass mich niemand
überfährt und so weiter moderne
gesellschaften beruhen ganz zentrale
auch vertrauen und das wird jetzt so
sichtbar in dieser in dieser krise weil
weil das vertrauen gerade bröckelt ja
also in experten weil eben diese
krankheit uns sozusagen wirklich
leidlich unmittelbar betrifft und wir
jetzt gerade in dieser umfrage also
impfen ist eben noch mal was anderes als
ein auto steigen da wird mir irgendwas
indiziert das macht was mit meinem
körper
und da wird es so sichtbar und da könnte
man jetzt auf der einen seite natürlich
sagen ja wieso wir vertrauen ja ein ganz
vielen anderen bereichen auch also warum
denn nicht jetzt auch und da muss ich
sagen weil einfach immer noch so viele
informationen fehlen und ich mich ich
kann mir im moment gar kein richtiges
urteil bilden also zum beispiel weiß man
immer noch nicht soweit ich das mit
verfolge ob denn diese impfstoffe nur
vermeiden dass die krankheit bei mir
ausbricht oder auch ob ich ansteckend
binden das ist ein ganz krise
riesengroßer unterschied also dass also
wenn sozusagen dieses wir diese dieser
impfstoff gar nicht verhindert dass sich
anstecken bin dann fällt schon mal das
ethische argumente
du musst dich aber impfen weil das ist
uns unsolidarisch fällt dann schon mal
weg aber gerade frau flaßpöhler wenn ich
das sagen darf weil so vieles wie sie
richtig sagen ja noch im ungewissen ist
wie es schlichtweg nicht beantworten
können ist es natürlich auch ein trial
and error antasten was ist der richtige
weg
an der stelle möchte ich gerne mal boris
palmer ins boot holen wir haben es jetzt
ein paar mal schon angedeutet sie sind
der oberbürgermeister von tübingen und
sie sind da einen sehr eigenen weg
gegangen was ist das erfolgsgeheimnis
das schreiben sie mal die maßnahmen ich
versuch's mal zu beschreiben das ist ja
sehr klar dass das risiko bei den
älteren menschen ganz besonders
fokussiert ist 90 prozent der todesfälle
ist in über 65 jahre alt mit corona und
das wissen wir schon seit einem halben
jahr
und deswegen war ich der meinung wir
müssen den schutzwall aufbauen für die
älteren in unserer gesellschaft wenn das
risiko von menschen über 80 500 mal
höher ist als für die unter 40 dann ist
doch nicht gerecht den gleichen schutz
für die über 80 jährigen sagen da
brauchen die besonderen schutz das war
der gedanke und dann haben wir überlegt
was kann man in der stadt machen wir
haben eine großartige bak präsidentin
die hat sofort angefangen zu sagen dann
müssen wir jetzt alle altenheime durch
testen egal ob das symptome sind oder
nicht und sofort haben wir infektionen
gefunden und konnten die
weiterverbreitung zu verhindern
die gleiche notärztin lisa federle hat
jetzt vor zwei monaten gesagt wir kaufen
die schnelltests für tübingen einfach am
ersten tag der verfügbarkeit und jetzt
kann man in tübingen auf dem marktplatz
bevor man die eigenen angehörigen
besucht mit schnelltest machen und dann
weiß man ob man ansteckend ist wenn man
die oma besucht das macht weihnachten
sehr viel ruhiger und friedlicher
zutaten kann den zahlen auf null
gekriegt bei über 75 jährigen wir hatten
jetzt zwei wochen lang eine infektion
bei über 75 jährigen sind noch weitere
elemente also testen ist sehr wichtig
wir haben gesagt es ist nicht gut in der
stadt mit einer universität vielen
schulen schulzentrum für der region
kindergärten wenn da die alten leute mit
den jungen in den bussen fahren müssen
einmal gesagt zum preis des busses
dürftiger taxi fahren neben die sehr
gerne in anspruch sind dann nicht in der
infektionsgefahr im bus wir haben gesagt
wir brauchen dringend den medizinischen
schutzmasken die fsp zwei masken ich
höre der bund wird irgendwann jetzt
anfangen die zu liefern
wir haben sie anfang november an alle
haushalte mit personen über 65
ausgeliehen versucht den leuten die
chance zu geben sich zu schützen
im grunde genommen ein paar mal retten
sie mit dem konzept was sie gerade
beschrieben haben jetzt genau die alten
von denen sie im april noch gesagt haben
die könnten ja möglicherweise sowieso in
einem halben jahr tot sein
daraufhin haben sie einen ziemlichen
schiffstouren kaserne viel kritik auch
in der eigenen partei bei den grünen
haben sie daraus gelernt
nein ich habe damals gerade das gleiche
gemeint mich nur dumm ausgedrückt als
mathematiker war für mich begriff der
lebenserwartung unproblematisch ich
finde das nicht schlimm das zu sagen
weil wir werden alle irgendwann sterben
und die daten waren zur heute wissen wir
etwa drei jahre ist die lebenserwartung
der menschen noch gewesen die damals ein
corona in deutschland gestorben sind im
durchschnitt
das habe ich damals thematisieren wollen
aber nicht in der absicht dass die leute
dann keinen schutz brauchen sondern dass
wir einen schutz finden müssen wenn wir
wissen das sind genau die menschen die
betreut sind zum beispiel des virus
nicht in die altenheime
zu lassen ja und da würde ich gerade vor
drei jahren noch mal mit ins boot hole
herr palmer sagt ja sind sinngemäß man
redet zwar viel über senioren aber man
tut am ende zu wenig würden sie sich den
schuh anziehen
ich will sagen dass herr palmer was er
jetzt in tübingen gezeigt hat schon
wirklich mehr als respektabel ist er ist
wirklich absolut überzeugend vorgegangen
und da kann man es ja was abschauen wir
haben uns auch etwas abgeschaut dem
rheinland pfalz weil natürlich die
älteren nicht aus dem blick waren auch
nicht dass die bullen gruppen sind und
dass man sich ganz besonders schützen
muss aber tübingen ist eine start und
das ist schon nicht ganz so einfach das
genauso zu organisieren für ein ganzes
land ich glaube herr palmer sind 1000
bewohner bewohnerinnen wenn ich das
richtig gelesen habe ich weiß es nicht
genau zehn einrichtungen oder so ähnlich
wie haben 550 einrichtungen oder das was
im ganzen land aber wir haben in unserer
rechtsverordnung inzwischen auch auch
gucken nach tübingen geregelt dass die
leute wirklich auch getestet werden die
mitarbeiter zwei mal dort für die
hotspots ins die bewohner
wir werden jetzt auch diese änderung
vornehmen dass wir nur noch bewohner
monarch besucherreihen lassen die dann
wirklich auch ein test gemacht haben
weil wir die feststellung gemacht haben
wir haben schon länger die regelung sie
müssen ffp zwei masken tragen dass dies
einfach nicht konsequent tun und auch
die alten habe völlig überfordert sind
das wirklich jetzt alles zu
kontrollieren
dh wir sind auf diesem weg wie im ganzen
land aber es ist schon eine tolle sache
meine stadt wirklich so auch
vorangegangen ist aber es muss unser
aller ziel sein genau das umzusetzen was
wir auch von tübingen lernen können und
die tests verordnung ist er seit einiger
zeit auch da dass diese tests eben auch
zur verfügung stellen wir haben als spd
länder für die kanzler runde auch
eingebracht dass wir unbedingt wollen
dass bundesweit geregelt wird das
tatsächlich auch die mitarbeiter die
bewohner getestet betten müssen und dass
es eben auch die option gibt dass die
besucher an besucherinnen getestet
werden das finde ich einen ganz
wichtigen punkt dass wir das auch
bundesweit genauso handhaben in zukunft
in dem was sie da sagen frau dreyer und
was herr palmer auch praktiziert hat ist
ja auch ein stück generationenkonflikt
will ich nicht sagen aber das sind
unterschiedliche interessen frau
flaßpöhler wenn man die junge generation
x sieht die unter 20-jährigen
die wollen natürlich feiern die wollen
sich beweisen die wollen sich zeigen und
wissen noch dazu dass sie faktisch nicht
betroffen sind oder nicht sehr bedroht
sind von diesem virus
ich glaube in der ganzen krise bisher
sind zehn menschen unter 20 jahren in
deutschland gestorben
sieben davon ist man nicht mal klar dass
es mit 19 war kann man von denen
eigentlich seine solidarität verlangen
über so eine lange zeit ja also ich
meine man muss es jetzt in dieser
situation in der wir jetzt aktuell
stecken aber ich finde dass eben das
meinte ich eingangs dass ich das schon
so empfinde dass wir natürlich dieser
generation auch gegenüber verpflichtet
sind uns auch und solidarisch zeigen
müssen und ich hab da neulich einen sehr
interessanten ansatz gehört von dem
rechtsphilosophen reinhard merkel der
schub nämlich vor dass man die jungen
und die jugendlichen als erste impfen
sollte nämlich zum einen weil die nicht
so empfindlich reagieren auf diesen
impfstoff den man ja noch gar nicht
wirklich kennt also das ist ja ein
anderer impfstoff als man normalerweise
mit dem man normalerweise gehen oder
aber weil ich kurz dazwischen gehen darf
ja nur dann funktionieren das hatten
sich vorher gefragt werden der geimpfte
selbst nicht mehr zum spray werden genau
das ist sowieso da sie sowieso aber also
das ist ja das ist der eine grund ein
weiterer grund ist natürlich dass unter
den jugendlichen und kindern einfach die
super spacer sind weil die gar nicht
merken dass die kranken und ein dritter
grund ist genau das was sie angesprochen
haben nämlich dass die das sind die die
am beginn ihres lebens stehen ja die
irgendwie gerade reisen wollen die welt
erfahren wollen
und das können sie nur wenn sie
immunisiert sind also das finde ich
eigentlich einen bedenkenswerten
vorschläge habt bedenkenswert aber er
scheitert an der menge weil wir haben
viele junge leute die wir sofort impfen
müssten wir haben aber relativ wenig
impfstoff und deswegen schneiden sich
hier zwei werte der eine wert ist der
den sie völlig richtig dargestellt haben
übrigens quarantäne war früher dass man
diejenigen weg sperrte die potenzielle
infektionen waren um die anderen zu
schützen heute sperren wir die weg die
alten weg damit die jungen solisten
fröhlich frei weiterleben können hätten
wir für alle sofort impfstoff der so
tolle idee von der merkel aber das haben
wir nicht also müssen wir mit denen
anfangen die am größten gefahr potenzial
haben müssen also die alten motiv risiko
beladen ist der impfstoff in unserer
diskussion bisher auch in dem was sie
gerade gesagt
herr montgomery so eine art hoffnung
natürlich am horizont und er könnte frau
flach bilder so eine art game changer
werden und eine wende schaffen
sehen sie darin auch eine gefahr also
erstmal will ich ich bin auch ein fan
der modernen medizin ich habe auch meine
kinder impfen lassen ja ich bin jetzt
überhaupt keine imkerin oder gegnerin
ich finde nur diese das ebenso als
heilsversprechen zu stilisieren ja wenn
wir das geschafft haben wir die
ziellinie geschafft haben dann ist alles
gut das halte ich für einen fehler weil
wir müssen ja davon ausgehen dass diese
pandemie auch nicht die letzte gewesen
sein wird das heißt wir müssen diese
gesellschaft resilient machen und
resilienz ist was anderes als immunität
resilienz heiner schanz
widerstandsfähigkeit und das heißt dass
man an äußeren störungen dass man
sozusagen flexibel darauf reagiert und
sogar an ihnen wächst und eben präventiv
handeln kann was die zukunft angeht und
das würde aus meiner sicht zum beispiel
da gibt es ganz viele punkte die man
jetzt nennen könnte aber einer ist ja
zum beispiel das ja dieses virus bei den
jüngeren deshalb auch zum teil doch
angreifen kann weil einfach weltweit der
gesundheitszustand eigentlich nicht so
gut ist wie er sein könnte also
stichwort fettleibigkeit stichwort
atemwegsbeschwerden durch
luftverschmutzung erhöhter
blutzuckerspiegel und so weiter also
wenn man mal dafür sorgen würde dass die
das so sehen nicht alle probleme der
welt diese wir haben jetzt ein akutes
problem hoch akutes problem aber das
müssen wir jetzt lösen verstehe ich höre
was in anderen dingen zu das verstehe
ich aber wenn man immer nur sozusagen
aus dem sachzwang heraus und ganz ganz
schnell und ganz ganz schnell
ja ich stehe das zehn monate zeit das
sagen
diese corona pandemie ist doch
eigentlich das eingreifen zur ereignis
im medizinischen bereich dass wir erlebt
haben seit der spanischen grippe nach
dem ersten weltkrieg so ich kann mich
jedenfalls in meinem lebzeiten keinen
vergleichbaren vorgang erinnern
und weil es so tückisch ist und weil es
so gefährlich ist und weil wir eben auch
gesehen haben dass es gar keine
endgültige nachfolge gibt wissen wir ja
auch dass wir wohl mit ihm noch eine
zeit lang werden leben müssen
trotz des impfstoffs also ich gehöre
nicht zu denen die sagen im sommer im
juni oder juli ist alles vorbei sondern
es kann besser werden es wird
hoffentlich besser diese hoffnung muss
man auch haben und behalten
aber ich finde diese einzigartigkeit der
gefährdung die rechtfertigt ist auch
dass wir jetzt diese priorisierung
vornehmen und sagen wir müssen uns mit
dieser herausforderung befassen
das bedeutet nicht dass wir uns nicht um
die behandlung von krebskrankheiten
kümmern und von masern und von der
pocken und von anderen geiseln der
menschheit aber das ist die
herausforderung jetzt unsere generation
der konkrete impfstoff ist ja nicht mal
in weiter ferne herr montgomery in
großbritannien wird er bereits
eingesetzt seit dieser woche allerdings
auch mit allergischen reaktionen die man
schon gesehen und den sie heißt kleinen
mengen und in sehr kleinen ente sind das
ganze ist ja in deutschland in mainz
entwickelt worden mit einem organischen
und entschuldigen dass wir uns modell
sind zwei firmen genau aber sind die
briten jetzt nicht in so einem offenen
feld versuch so eine art
versuchskaninchen
naja ich glaube die werden eher das ist
er einen politischen prozess in
großbritannien die schüler selber auch
noch brite nebenbei muss man sagen das
hat mehr was mit der innenpolitik in
england zu tun
ich halte das für völlig falsch ich
wollte den weg die das schon hier hilft
wird ja und zwar eine notfall zulassung
das erzeugt genau das was hofft müller
erwähnt hat unsicherheit bei den
menschen und wenn wir die menschen nicht
mitnehmen eine impfpflicht kann es so
lange nicht geben wie einen impfstoff
nicht sehr sehr lange ausgetestet ist
und wer das risiko profil genau kennen
deswegen muss jetzt dieser prozess
durchgegangen werden den die europäische
union sieht dass die europäische
zulassungsbehörde den impfstoff zulässt
wir haben zeit bis zum 29 dezember dann
haben wir ein geordnetes
wissenschaftlich nachvollzogen das
verfahren und dennoch wird es nicht alle
menschen erreichen und man muss nur
eines sehen wenn wir momentan wollen 60
prozent der menschen sich schnell impfen
lassen
wenn wir das in der bundesrepublik
schaffen dann haben wir am ende immer
noch 38 millionen menschen die entweder
im versager sind wohl zehn prozent sind
im versager auch bei dem neuen impfstoff
oder die sich nicht haben impfen lassen
dann ist immer noch zwischen einem
drittel und der hälfte der bevölkerung
nicht immunisiert und auch die müssen
wir weiter schützen
also wer glaubt mit der impfung soll
alles erledigt
jedenfalls kommt nur noch kurz ab dem
moment jetzt und nicht so weit nach
vorne denn vielleicht sind wir in
deutschland ja tatsächlich ganz froh
dass nicht wir die ersten sind die
erfahrung in der praxis sammeln
mit diesen neuen impfstoff
[Musik]
die briten fackeln nicht lange mit
notfall zulassung wird auf der insel
schon geimpft
der britische premier ganz in seinem
element
es ist so bewegen madlin zu sprechen sie
ist 81 und sie hat gesagt sie tut es für
großbritannien
noch ist unklar wann wir unseren
patriotischen peaks bekommen
doch die in aussicht gestellte
normalisierung im kommenden jahr wird
schon wieder einkassieren
ich glaube nicht dass 2021 genug
menschen geimpft werden um ausreichend
epidemiologische effekte zu erzielen
heißt konkret keine entwarnung vor 2022
nicht miteingerechnet mögliche
allergische reaktionen wie aus england
gemeldet die das vertrauen erschüttern
und die verengung bremsen könnten
zumal immer wieder beteuert wird ich
denke aber eine impfpflicht derzeit
braucht es nicht also ich bin auch ab
sind gegen eine fliege ich gebe ihnen
mein wort es wird in dieser pandemie
keine infos geben keine impfpflicht
heißt aber auch es könnte sogar noch
länger dauern die pandemie zu besiegen
denn gebrauchen 55 bis 65 prozent der
bürger die sich impfen lassen um dort
auch insgesamt eine immunität der
herdenimmunität wie man es nennt zu
erreichen
da hat man ja was glauben sie wie lange
wird es dauern wenn geimpft wird und das
ganze funktioniert bis der alltag im
sinne einer erleichterung für die
menschen sich verändert ja gut ist hängt
von zwei faktoren ab das eine ist der
faktor
wann sind genügend impfdosen vorhanden
wir reservieren die impfdosen ja nicht
für einige wenige länder die sich das
leisten können sondern die impfdosen
werden in der ganzen welt verteilt und
verfügbar gemacht und die zweite frage
ist ob es medizinische probleme und
verzögerungen gibt die wir jetzt nicht
absehen können
ich hoffe nein ich habe jedenfalls
vertrauen darin dass gute arbeit
geleistet worden ist ich sage aber auch
ich bin auch froh dass die europäische
zulassungsbehörde ema sich nicht unter
druck setzen lässt und dass sie nach den
vorgeschriebenen regeln vorgehen die
haben ja alle ihren grund und auch das
kann am ende
leben zu retten ich habe am wochenende
zu hause im wo ich wohne mit einigen
nachbarn und bekannten gesprochen und
ich glaube die bereitschaft sich impfen
zu lassen ist hoch aber noch einmal ich
glaube tatsächlich nicht dass wir alle
sorgen los sind in einigen monaten
sondern die pandemie wird uns
beschäftigen
sie wird über immer dann wenn viele
menschen zusammenkommen
auch immer mal wieder aufflackern und
was nicht umtreibt ist die frage warum
haben wir es nicht geschafft dort wo das
passiert ist das viel besser im keim zu
ersticken
und da wir wissen ja es ist geschehen
als viele menschen im urlaub waren nicht
nur im ausland auch innerhalb von
deutschland
wir wissen es ist geschehen wenn
menschen zusammenkamen sehr eng in
sozial und der mensch ist ja ein
geselliges leben so und da werden wir
uns an regeln halten müssen und wir
werden wahrscheinlich auch noch länger
masken tragen müssen wir haben früher
manchmal gelächelt wenn wir asiatische
bürgersaal auf unseren flughäfen die mit
masken herumgelaufen sind weil sie
andere schützen wollten
weil es in anderen kann der verein es
ist eine ich mag die auch nicht
besonders weil mir die brille beschlägt
und dann kann ich kann ich die die
ketten nicht lesen aber es ist nun
einmal so dass es für alle beteiligten
besser ist und deshalb müssen wir den
menschen sagen schmeißt eure maske nicht
weg wenn er hört dass die ersten
impfungen erfolgreich waren
wir werden damit noch lange zu tun haben
frau dreyer wir haben sie zwar gerade im
einspielfilm schon gehört das hindert
mich aber nicht dran trotzdem noch mal
nachzufragen wenn die 55 bis 65 prozent
durch impfungen es jetzt mal die der
bundesgesundheitsminister gerade
passiert dass man sie braucht wenn das
nicht erreicht wird kommt dann nicht
doch die impfpflicht
nein also ich glaube schon dass wir als
politiker da wirklich glaubwürdig
bleiben müssen wir haben von anfang an
gesagt dass wir menschen überzeugen
wollen wenn wir von dem impfen überzeugt
sind
das heißt wir müssen transparent sein
wir müssen erklären wir müssen
sicherstellen dass ausreichend
medizinische beratung da ist und wir
müssen auch priorisieren wie es eben
gesagt worden ist
meine anregung hin hat unser parlament
heute eine orientierungs debatte zu
diesem thema gehabt und es gab doch eine
ziemlich breite einigkeit darüber dass
beispielsweise jetzt erstmal die älteren
menschen auch in den heimen geimpft
werden nicht nur weil sie die im
empfindlichsten sind oder gefährdet sind
auch weil wir unbedingt unser
gesundheitssystem entlasten müssen und
das ist nun mal eine tatsache dass zur
zeit eben die allermeisten menschen in
unseren krankenhäusern wirklich auch die
hochbetagten sind insofern des impfen
ist kein allheilmittel und das ist jetzt
von allen eigentlich auch gesagt worden
aber es ist trotzdem ein ganzes stück
berechtigte hoffnung auch dass es damit
natürlich die gesamtlage auch ein ganzes
stück ländern wird und wenn es uns
gelingt schon mal die variablen gruppen
wirklich aussen vor zu haben aus der
gefährdung dann sind wir ein riesiges
stück weiter in deutschland heute gab es
auch gute nachrichten bezogen aus auf
ein mögliches medikament aus bayern
ich glaube es gibt viele module die uns
helfen werden diese pandemie gut und
besser in den griff zu bekommen
aber eins ist für mich völlig klar wir
sollten nicht mit der keule impfpflicht
drohen auch nicht mittelbar sondern wir
sollten deutlich machen
wir wollen die menschen überzeugen wir
wollen aufklären man muss alle fragen
beantworten auch zu möglichen
nebenwirkungen damit die menschen sich
verantwortlich dann auch diese
entscheidung stellen dürfen und was ich
weiß gerade die wohlhabenden die älteren
gruppen die chronisch kranken menschen
da gibt es auch eine große bereitschaft
zum impfen und darauf sollten wir setzen
und alles dafür tun das ist auch
funktioniert ich höre ihre
entschlossenheit und auch die von jens
spahn ein einer impfpflicht wird es
nicht geben ist die klare aussage ich
frag trotz noch mal in die runde
wie groß ist denn die gefahr dass das
ganze durch die hintertür kommt das dann
fluglinien sagen hier steigt nur noch
ein wer geimpft ist oder
restaurantbesitzer das tun kann man das
ausschließen
wir haben schon sehr früh in der debatte
um einen immunität nachweis mit jens
spahn auch gerungen
da geht es genau um die frei das wird
irgendwann kommen irgendwann werden sie
für bestimmte leistungen im qualitäts
nachweis bringen müssen der muss aber
erstmal valide sein das gibt's ja heute
noch gar nicht
wir können heute immunität noch nicht
eindeutig nach was man doch
cryptic ich bin da echt dagegen ja aber
wenn sie sich mit grippe holen beim
fliegen das werden sie lieben die sonne
unbedingt ein tödlicher das klassische
ronald ist ja so eine die matte lasst
uns eine sache sagen haben wir beide
werden über diese frage noch viel
diskutieren müssen weil man wird sich am
ende mit der solidarität wieder fragen
sollen werden diejenigen die sich haben
impfen lassen
und diejenigen die sich verweigert haben
der impfung werden die vorteile haben
oder nachteile haben in der debatte ist
noch nicht wieder ganz an gegen ich
finde auch für falsch ich finde es echt
falsch wenn wir werben wollen für die
impfung da dürfen wir jetzt nicht schon
die die sich aus individuellen gründen
dagegen entscheiden als verweigerte
abkanzeln und ich bin strikt dagegen
da irgendwelche nachteile für die leute
die sich gegen die impfung zu
entscheiden wo wir eigentlich schon
sagen darf man sagen warum ich bin
dagegen weil es die impfbereitschaft
senkt und weil es unverhältnismäßig ist
es ist unverhältnismäßig weil das
problem von corona nicht die
individuelle todes gefahr ist und die
schwere erkrankung da wissen wir die
letalität ist bei weitem geringer als
befürchtet im april die vanitas studie
0,4 prozent schwelle
die letalität ist nicht so dramatisch
das problem an corona es ausschließlich
dass unser gesundheitssystem überrollt
und wie wir so viele impfen dass das
gesundheitssystem sicher ist dann ist es
individuelle entscheidung und
eigenverantwortung da muss man niemand
dazu zwingen da man irgendwann nicht
impfen lässt muss zumindest zum schutz
der anderen dann weiter eine maske
tragen
darum versuchen uns doch auch muss
demnach impfte verliehen werden das
nicht hören sie jahre masken tragen
müssen